WILL CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
DALY. DODD. DURAZZO EGGMAN.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD. LIMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. RATH. RUBIO. CIERTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMMER. WAHAB. WIENER. WILK
. A QUORUM IS PRESENT. MEMBERS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SENATE RULE
55 WILL BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW
GUESTS ON THE FLOOR FOR TODAY'S
FLOOR SESSION, WITH THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR RUBIO, AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. US SENATOR
RUBIO, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. BOW YOUR HEADS.
GRACIOUS GOD, YOU MEET US IN
UNEXPECTED PLACES. TRACES OF
YOUR GRACE ARE STREWN ALL OVER
OUR SCHEDULE. HEAVY LIVES. WE
ASK TO BE STIRRED AND DISTURBED
TOWARDS SOUL SATISFYING RESULTS.
AND OUR DESIRE TO SERVE YOU AND
NEIGHBOR AND EVEN OUR ENEMY,
EASE US INTO BEING GOOD
SAMARITANS TO EACH OTHER, TO THE
OUTCASTS, AND REJECT AT ONCE,
AND TO DO THOSE WHOSE FEAR
SOMETIMES MAKES THEM OBNOXIOUS,
MAKE US BOLD, TO CALL OTHERS TO
ACCOUNTABILITY, EVEN AS WE MODEL
HUMILITY TO THE ARROGANT MERCY
TO THE SELF-RIGHTEOUS,
COMPASSION TO THE INDIFFERENT.
GOD OF MANY SURPRISES MAKE US
GLAD OF OUR HEART FOR EACH
OTHER'S DAYS. OPPORTUNITIES TO
BRING OUR IMAGINATION AND
CREATIVITY TO THE DISTURBANCE
CAUSES THAT THREATEN TO
DISCOURAGE US. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE IN THE IMPOSSIBLE.
AMEN. AMEN PLEASE PLACE YOUR
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART.
BEGIN. I PLEDGE. STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS. WE
HAVE A WONDERFULLY PACKED
SESSION TODAY. I ASK THAT FOR
THE REMAINING OF OUR SESSIONS,
IF WE WANT TO HAVE WONDERFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES, WE COULD TAKE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR AND
GIVE OUR ATTENTION TO OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE A LOT OF
PRESENTATIONS. ALL RIGHT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL TAKE
UP THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS OUT
OF ORDER TODAY. FILE ITEM 11 SR
74. FILE ITEM TEN, SCR 124, AND
FILE ITEM 51 SCR 101. AFTER
ADOPTION OF THESE EACH
RESOLUTION WE WILL RETURN TO THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR THE
AUTHOR TO INTRODUCE THEIR GUEST.
WE WILL START. SENATOR UMBERG,
IF YOU'RE PREPARED WITH THE
PRESENTATION. PLEASE PROCEED. DO
YOU WANT TO READ Ó, LET ME YOUR
YOUR PRIVILEGE IS YOUR GUEST
TODAY, SENATOR. OKAY. LET ME LET
ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. LET ME MAKE SOME
SPECIAL INTRODUCTIONS. IS WITH
US ON THE FLOOR TODAY. WE HAVE,
MAYOR VALEO SANTA ANA, LONGTIME
PRESIDENT OF UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. IF YOU'D ALL WELCOME
MAYOR MSBA. THANK YOU. WELCOME,
MAYOR. AND ALSO WITH US TODAY IS
COUNCIL MEMBER CONNOR TROUT, ONE
OF THE YOUNGEST ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HE SERVED AS MAYOR,
AND NOW HE'S COUNCIL MEMBER.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, HE'S A FATHER
AS OF THREE WEEKS AGO. SO THANK
YOU. WELCOME. COUNCIL MEMBER I
AM THE YOUNGEST MEMBER OF THIS
BODY HERE. SO WELCOME. YES,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. MOVING ON
TO SENATOR WILK. ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY? YES, MADAM PRESIDENT,
PLEASE PROCEED. TODAY, I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME MY GOOD FRIEND
KIM KOPPELMAN. KIM IS THE FORMER
NORTH DAKOTA SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE. HE SERVED IN THE NORTH
DAKOTA LEGISLATURE FOR 28 YEARS
BEFORE RETIRING IN 2022. KIM HAS
HAD A DISTINGUISHED CAREER IN
BUSINESS AND PUBLIC SERVICE,
INCLUDING SERVING SERVING AS THE
NATIONAL CHAIRMAN OF THE COUNCIL
OF STATE GOVERNMENTS. HE AND HIS
LOVELY WIFE TORI LIVE IN WEST
FARGO, WHERE HE REMAINS ACTIVE
IN PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND THE
COMMUNITY. PLEASE GIVE A WARM
SENATE WELCOME TO MISTER KIM
KOPPELMAN. WELCOME MR. SPEAKER.
SENATOR WILK, WOULD YOU LIKE A
PHOTO WITH YOUR GUEST? I PUT A
LITTLE WEIGHT ON LATELY, SO NO,
NO, I WILL.
LET'S DO THIS. LET'S DO FIRST
SENATOR UMBERG WITH HIS GUESTS
.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN A GROUP PHOTO? OR
NOT? OKAY OKAY, OKAY. MOVING ON
TO SENATOR LAIRD. FIREARM, TEN
SCR 124. SENATOR, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 124
BY SENATOR LAIRD RELATIVE TO
CYSTIC FIBROSIS AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 124, WHICH
DECLARES MAY CYSTIC FIBROSIS
MONTH Ã. CYSTIC FIBROSIS IS A
RARE DISEASE DIAGNOSED IN
APPROXIMATELY 2500 PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. YET I THINK MANY OF
US KNOW SOMEONE IN THAT
CATEGORY. THIS IS MOST KNOWN FOR
CAUSING PROGRESSIVE LUNG
DISEASE, CYSTIC FIBROSIS, OR CF,
IMPACTS EVERY ORGAN SYSTEM IN
THE BODY. RAISING AWARENESS IS
KEY WITH AWARENESS COMES SUPPORT
FOR RESEARCH AND UNTIL RECENTLY,
LIFE EXPECTANCY FOR THOSE WITH
CF WAS SHORT THANKS TO
INNOVATIVE RESEARCH, NEW
THERAPIES HAVE DEVELOPED THAT
WILL TRANSFORM THE COURSE OF THE
DISEASE. FOR MANY, HOWEVER,
THERE IS NO CURE FOR CYSTIC
FIBROSIS FOR THOSE WITH ADVANCED
LUNG DISEASE, THESE THERAPIES
COME TOO LATE AND THERE ARE MANY
WITH CF. MOST SIGNIFICANTLY,
PEOPLE OF COLOR FOR WHOM THE NEW
MEDICATIONS ARE NOT EFFECTIVE.
SO IT IMPACTS PEOPLE OF EVERY
RACE AND ETHNICITY. PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO GO
UNDER DIAGNOSED DUE TO
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH CARE
RAISING, AWARENESS OF CYSTIC
FIBROSIS, AND THE DIVERSITY OF
THOSE IMPACTED WILL LEAD TO
EARLIER DIAGNOSIS AND LIFE
SAVING INTERVENTIONS, WHICH IS
WHY THIS RESOLUTION IS BEING
DONE TODAY. SINCE 1975, CYSTIC
FIBROSIS RESEARCH INSTITUTE HAS
BEEN FUNDING RESEARCH TO MOVE US
CLOSER TO A CURE WHILE PROVIDING
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT SERVICES
TO THOSE IMPACTED BY THE
DISEASE. BUT THERE IS STILL WORK
TO BE DONE TO FIND A CURE AND TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECEIVE A DIAGNOSIS AND
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT FOR THE
DISEASE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SCR 124 SENATORS.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY.
MIN. STERN. STERN. AYE AYES 38.
NO. ZERO. RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SENATOR LAIRD, PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM PRESIDENT,
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING IN THE
GALLERY TODAY, THE CYSTIC
FIBROSIS RESEARCH INSTITUTE, AND
THANK THEM FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. THEIR ADVOCATES
VISITING TODAY FROM SANTA CRUZ,
SANTA CLARA, SAN MATEO, ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND CITIES IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. THEY'RE HERE ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS, FAMILY AND
THEMSELVES TO ADVOCATE AND RAISE
AWARENESS FOR THOSE WITH CYSTIC
FIBROSIS. PLEASE WELCOME THEM TO
THE STATE SENATE. WELCOME. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 51 SCR
101. SENATOR NGUYEN FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. ARE YOU
PREPARED? YES, SECRETARY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 101 BY
SENATOR NGUYEN RELATIVE TO
ALLIED. PLEASE PROCEED. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR, COLLEAGUES, WE HAVE
WE'RE HEARING A RESOLUTION AND
WE COULD TAKE OUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR. GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SENATOR. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 101. SCR
101 RECOGNIZES MAY 15TH AS HØI
DAY DURING ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH.
I STARTED THIS RECOGNITION BACK
IN 2016 WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF
SR 73. THE VIETNAMESE AND
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN CULTURES ARE
BRIGHT, COLORFUL, AND FULL OF
HISTORY. THAT THAT IS, THAT IT
CAPTURED IN THE FORM OF THE
ALII. THE NATIONAL GOVERNMENT OF
VIETNAM. SO HOW IS SHIRT YAI
LONG? SO IT'S A LONG SHIRT. THE
NATIONAL GARMENT OF VIETNAM,
WORN ON ALL OCCASIONS. WHETHER
IT'S A FORMAL BUSINESS MEETING,
IT COULD BE AT A GALA WEDDING.
IT COULD EVEN BE WORN DAILY AS
WELL. THE SYMBOL, THE SYMBOL OF
NATIONAL PRIDE, HAS BEEN WORN BY
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN AND HAS
EVOLVED FROM A SIMPLE, LOOSE
FITTING GARMENT TO THE ELABORATE
WORKS OF ART THAT ARE SEEN IN
CEREMONIES AND ALSO MUSEUMS. I'M
SO PROUD THAT THIS ENDURING
SYMBOL IS SOMETHING THAT I CAN
SHARE WITH MY CHILDREN. I WATCH
AS THEY EMBRACE THEIR HERITAGE
AND ENJOY WEARING THE ALII
DURING HOLIDAYS, AND EVEN AN
EVENTS LIKE TET AND THE
VIETNAMESE NEW YEAR. AS THE
MONTH OF MAY MARKS ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
HERITAGE MONTH, THERE'S NO
BETTER TIME TO HONOR THE ALII
AND THE PEOPLE AND HISTORY IT
REPRESENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLE.
ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING
NONE. AYES 38. NØ ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. SENATOR,
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, HERE I HAVE WITH ME
ARE OUR FIVE CONSTITUENTS FROM
MY DISTRICT. TRICIA NGUYEN,
DIANA NGUYEN, MICHELLE TRAN,
JOSEPHINE TRINA DOE AND MICHELLE
DOE, WHO ARE ALL WEARING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ALII
REPRESENTING THE COUNTRY OF
VIETNAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
PLEASE GIVE THEM A BIG ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR BEING UP HERE.
WELCOME TO THE STATE SENATE.
SENATOR NGUYEN, YOU WILL HAVE
YOU TAKE A PHOTO. THERE WE GO.
MEMBERS, IF YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN
THIS PHOTO, THIS GROUP PHOTO NOW
IS THE TIME
.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE AGENDA.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WERE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WOULD BE
DEEMED READ, AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. ADOPTED MOVING NOW TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR APRIL 29TH, 2024
THROUGH MAY 2ND, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. NOW, IN
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE
STARTING WITH THE SECOND READING
FILE, WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1141 WITH AMENDMENTS MOVING
ON TO SENATE THIRD READING. WE
JUST HAVE ONE ITEM. ITEM NINE,
AND I ASK THAT WE COULD CONTINUE
TO REMOVE OUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR AND GIVE OUR
ATTENTION, SENATOR UMBERG, ARE
YOU PREPARED? I AM, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ON. ITEM NUMBER NINE. GIVE
US A MINUTE HERE, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ITEM NUMBER NINE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 110
BY SENATOR UMBERG, RELATIVE TO
PEACE OFFICERS. SEN UMBERG, MAY
I PROCEED? THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT SCR 110 IN HONOR OF
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY, A DAY THAT
CALIFORNIANS OBSERVE IN
COMMEMORATION OF THE OFFICERS
WHO HAVE TRAGICALLY SACRIFICED
THEIR LIVES FOR ALL OF US. LET
ME BEGIN BY READING A QUOTE FROM
THE GOSPEL OF JOHN, CHAPTER 15,
VERSE 12. SO THIS IS MY COMMAND.
LOVE EACH OTHER DEEPLY, AS MUCH
AS I HAVE LOVED YOU, FOR THE
GREATEST LOVE OF ALL IS A LOVE
THAT SACRIFICES ALL. GREATER
LOVE HATH NO MAN THAN THIS. THAT
A MAN LAY DOWN HIS LIFE FOR HIS
FRIENDS. TODAY WE HONOR THOSE
WHO HAVE LAID DOWN THEIR LIFE
FOR ALL OF US, ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS ARE INDEBTED
TO OUR PEACE OFFICERS EACH AND
EVERY DAY, TODAY WE MAKE
PARTICULAR NOTE OF THE PEACE
OFFICERS WHO SERVICE BRAVERY AND
DEDICATION IS HONORED AND
REVERED, MANY OF US WERE AT THE
PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL THIS
MORNING, AND IT'S APPROPRIATE
THAT WE AS A STATE, RECOGNIZE
THEIR SACRIFICE. AND IMPORTANTLY
, THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE FAMILIES
WHO ARE LEFT BEHIND AND THE
LOVED ONES OF THOSE OFFICERS WHO
CONTINUE TO MAKE THAT SACRIFICE
ON A DAILY BASIS. THE FAMILIES
WHO FEEL THAT LOSS EVERY DAY,
THE FAMILIES WHO CONTINUE TO
BEAR THAT SACRIFICE ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF US, THE FAMILIES WHO MUST
KEEP ON LIVING, ALTHOUGH THEIR
HEARTS ARE SO HEAVY THAT IT'S
HARD TO DO. ALTHOUGH THE
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS, THE PEACE
OFFICERS, THEY'VE SAFEGUARDED
OUR LIVES, OUR PROPERTY, THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA AND THOSE
TODAY WE HONOR GAVE THE FULL
MEASURE OF THAT DEVOTION. THÀNH.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL CEREMONY, AS
WE SHOULD, TO RECOGNIZE THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES, THIS CEREMONY,
THIS COMMEMORATION DOESN'T COME
ABOUT ORGANICALLY. IT REQUIRES
LEADERSHIP AND ORGANIZATION. AND
IT'S THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL FOUNDATION
THAT ORGANIZES THIS EVENT EVERY
YEAR. AND CONTINUES TO RECOGNIZE
AND REMEMBER THOSE WHO ARE
SURVIVORS. AND TODAY WE HAVE
THREE FOLKS WHO ARE PRESENT IN
THE GALLERY. WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL
FOUNDATION, JUAN MIRAMONTES, WHO
IS HERE WITH US TODAY ALONG WITH
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, MARK
NICHOLS. AND WE HAVE DIRECTOR,
JOHN KACZOROWSKI, WHO'S ALSO
HERE WITH US TODAY. WE THANK
THEM. WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
DEDICATION AND THEIR DEVOTION TO
THESE FAMILIES, LET ME TODAY
RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO HAVE DIED IN
THE LINE OF DUTY. OFFICER PHILIP
SODARO, LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT, END OF WATCH.
JANUARY 25TH, 2021. SERGEANT
PATRICIA GUILLEN, LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT, END OF WATCH
JANUARY 28TH, 2021 SERGEANT
ANTHONY WHITE, LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH
APRIL 15TH, 2021 DEPUTY DARNELL
CALHOUN, RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE END OF WATCH
JANUARY 13TH, 2023 DEPUTY
CALHOUN WAS AMBUSHED AND FATALLY
SHOT IN LINE OF DUTY ON JANUARY
13TH. HE HAD SERVED ON THE FORCE
FOR LESS THAN A YEAR. HIS
PARENTS, SISTER, BROTHER, WIFE
AND THREE SONS SURVIVED HIM. THE
YOUNGEST SON WAS ACTUALLY BORN
AFTER DEPUTY CALHOUN WAS
MURDERED. OFFICER GONZALO
CARRASCO, SELMA POLICE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH JANUARY
31ST, 2023 OFFICER CARRASCO WAS
SHOT AND KILLED IN AN AMBUSH
ATTACK ON JANUARY 31ST, 2023. HE
WAS ONLY 24 YEARS OLD WITH TWO
YEARS OF SERVICE WITH THE SELMA
POLICE DEPARTMENT. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS PARENTS, HIS
SIBLINGS, HIS GIRLFRIEND WHO
GAVE BIRTH AGAIN TO A SON LESS
THAN A MONTH FOLLOWING HIS
DEATH. DEPUTY RYAN CLINKENBEARD,
FORMER LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT END OF
WATCH SEPTEMBER 16TH, 2023
DEPUTY CLINCOLN BREWER WAS AN
EIGHT YEAR VETERAN OF LA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. HE WAS
AMBUSHED AND FATALLY SHOT WHILE
SITTING AT A TRAFFIC STOP IN
FRONT OF A PALMDALE SHERIFF'S
STATION. DEPUTY CLINCOLN BREWER
IS SURVIVED BY HIS PARENTS,
GRANDPARENTS FIANCE, WHO HE
PROPOSED TO JUST FOUR DAYS
BEFORE THE ATTACK. AN OFFICER,
TUAN LEE, OAKLAND POLICE
DEPARTMENT END OF WATCH DECEMBER
29TH, 2023, ALL THESE OFFICERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES, WE HONOR AND
REVERE, AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO
DO SO. I ASK TODAY FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN RECOGNITION OF SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 110.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 110 PROCLAIMING
MONDAY, MAY 6TH, AS CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL DAY.
THIS RESOLUTION IS PERSONALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME AS IT IS TO THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED THIS
GREAT COUNTRY IN UNIFORM. AS WE
RECOGNIZE THOSE IN THE BALCONY.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. IT
PERSONALLY IS IMPORTANT TO ME
AGAIN THAT I SERVED WITH THE
MONTEBELLO POLICE DEPARTMENT. SO
AS BROTHER IN ARMS, I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE. OUR
PEACE OFFICERS PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY WORK DANGEROUSLY DIFFICULT
TIMES, DUTIES AND DAYS THAT
WITHOUT FAMILY, SOMETIMES JUST
THE BROTHER AND SISTER NEXT TO
HIM IN THE CAR. AND EVERY DAY
THEY'RE THERE TO PROTECT OUR
GREAT STATE AND OUR CITIES.
POLICE OFFICERS ARE PUBLIC
SERVANTS TO PROTECT US, SERVE
US, KEEP US SAFE, AND GENERALLY
CARE ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY REPRESENT. OUR
OFFICERS JOIN THE FORCE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A STRONG DESIRE TO
HELP PEOPLE AND OFTEN GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE CALL OF DUTY THAT
IS REQUIRED OF THEM ON A DAILY
BASIS. THEIR DEDICATION TO
KEEPING OUR COMMUNICATIONS SAFE,
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SOMETIMES IT'S
OVERSTATED BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THEY SACRIFICE SO MUCH, BUT
ONLY THE FAMILIES TRULY KNOW
WHEN THEY LOSE ONE. WE ARE
INDEBTED TO PUT OURSELVES
TOGETHER WITH THEM SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE TIME AND THE
SERVICE THEY GIVE OUR STATE.
SOMETIMES THE ULTIMATE PRICE.
THESE FALLEN HEROES WERE LAID TO
REST TODAY, SYMBOLICALLY, BUT
THERE WAS HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
ESPECIALLY THEIR FAMILIES. THERE
TO RECOGNIZE THEM. IT WAS AN
HONOR TO WITNESS THE HUNDREDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, MEN
AND WOMEN THIS MORNING AT THE
PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL CEREMONY
FROM SMALL DEPARTMENTS TO OUR
LARGEST, THE COMMON BOND, THE
BADGES THESE OFFICERS WEAR AND
SERVICE OF GOD AND COUNTRY AND
TO THEIR COMMUNITY, THE FAMILIES
ONCE AGAIN COME TOGETHER TO LAY
THE FLOWERS AT THE FOOT OF THE
MEMORIAL STATUE. IT BROUGHT
SADNESS TO THE TEARS AND EYES OF
EVERYONE THAT WAS THERE, AND THE
CHILDREN WHO SAID BY DAD, BYE
MOM, WE WILL NEVER KNOW THEIR
GRIEF, BUT WE WILL ALWAYS HONOR
THEIR SACRIFICES. SO FOR THESE
REASONS, I ASK THAT WE SUPPORT
SCR 110. THANK YOU, SENATOR
RUBIO. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I
ALSO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SCR 110. I WANT TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THOSE THAT HAVE
FALLEN IN THE LINE OF DUTY, AND
ALSO THANK ALL THOSE THAT CAME
FROM ACROSS OUR STATE TODAY TO
JUST BEAR WITNESS TO WHAT'S LEFT
BEHIND US AFTER THESE HEROES PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE AND
ULTIMATELY LOSE IT AND
PROTECTING US. SO TODAY, IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT. AS I WATCHED A
PARENT FAMILY MEMBER JUST BREAK
DOWN. AND I THINK THAT SOMETIMES
AS AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS, WE SEE
THE UNIFORM, WE SEE THE BADGE,
AND WE FAIL TO SEE WHAT'S BEHIND
THAT. AND WE DON'T SEE THE
SPOUSES, THE CHILDREN, THE
MOTHERS. AND IT'S JUST A
TESTAMENT OF HOW MUCH MORE WE
HAVE TO DO TO ENSURE THAT WE
UPLIFT THEM, SUPPORT THEM. AND
IN SO MANY WAYS, THERE ARE
COMMUNITY HEROES. I JUST WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE TWO
OF OUR OFFICERS THAT I LOST. WE
LOST AS A COMMUNITY LAST YEAR
AND WERE HONORED HERE AS WELL.
TO YOUNG MEN, OFFICER PAREDES
AND OFFICER SANTANA, VERY YOUNG,
YOUNG MEN WHO LEFT REALLY SMALL
CHILDREN BEHIND. AND AS YOU TALK
TO THE FAMILIES, THE MOTHERS,
THE CHILDREN, IT IS
HEARTBREAKING. AND SO I JUST
WANT TO ENCOURAGE US TO
COLLECTIVELY TAKE ONE MOMENT AS
A COMMUNITY, AS SOCIETY, AS A
STATE, TO SAY THANK YOU WHEN WE
SEE THEM, NOT JUST THE UNIFORM,
BUT THE HUMAN BEINGS WEARING THE
BADGE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR NGUYEN,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I TOO,
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 110, WHICH
DECLARE MAY 6TH, 2024 AS
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY TO HONOR THOSE WHO
HAVE DIED IN LINE OF DUTY AND TO
ALSO RECOGNIZE THEIR FAMILY, AND
TO THANK THEM FOR BEING, FOR
THEIR SACRIFICES DURING MY TIME
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE, I'VE
HAD THE UNFORTUNATE DUTY OF
HONORING THE LIVES OF TWO
OFFICERS IN MY DISTRICT WHO
PROUDLY SERVE AND PROTECTED OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SADLY LOST THEIR
LIVES IN THE LINE OF DUTY, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE BOTH OF
THEM AT THIS TIME IN 2022, WE
HONOR HUNTING BEACH POLICE
OFFICER NICHOLAS VELLA. OFFICER
VELLA GREW UP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SPENT 14 YEARS OF
HIS LIFE SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
HUNTING BEACH AS HIS AS A POLICE
OFFICER. HE DIED TRAGICALLY
DURING A HELICOPTER CRASH IN
NEWPORT BEACH WHILE RESPONDING
TO A TO A CALL IN THE
NEIGHBORING CITY OF NEWPORT
BEACH, A HOME SURVEILLANCE
CAMERA CAPTURED HIS HELICOPTER
AS IT WENT DOWN INTO THE WATER.
SINCE HIS SINCE HIS PASSING,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HONOR HIM
WITH A HIGHWAY SIGN IN HUNTING
BEACH, WHERE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE DRIVING ON BEACH
BOULEVARD WILL BE ABLE TO
REMEMBER AND HONOR HIM, LAST
YEAR, WE ALSO HONORED LAGUNA
BEACH POLICE OFFICER JOHN CðC
WITH A HIGHWAY MEMORIAL SIGN ON
ALICIA CREEK BRIDGE IN HONOR OF
HIS HEROIC ACTS, ACTS, AND HIS
SELFLESS SERVICE. HIS LIFE ENDED
BACK IN 2013. TÍNH AS OFFICER
CðC PURSUED A RECKLESS, DRIVING
DRIVEN VEHICLE THAT THAT HAD
ELUDED ANOTHER OFFICER FOLLOWING
ITS CHASE, A COLLISION ON THE
PACIFIC COAST HIGHWAY CLAIMED
HIS LIFE IN THE FACE OF THIS
HEARTBREAKING EVENT. ONE OF THE
RESPONDING OFFICERS DRAPED AN
AMERICAN FLAG OVER JOHN'S BODY,
AN HONORABLE GESTURE BEFITTING
OF A TRUE HERO WHO HAD DUTIFULLY
SERVED BOTH HIS COUNTRY AND HIS
COMMUNITY. THE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS LEAVE HOME EVERY DAY
REALIZING THAT THEY MIGHT NOT
RETURN HOME. POLICE OFFICERS ARE
SOME OF THE BRAVEST, DEDICATED
AND COMMITTED INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE STEPPED UP TO PROTECT AND
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES AS
GRATEFUL AS WE ARE FOR THEM, WE
MUST ALSO SHOW OUR GREAT
GRATITUDE AND APPRECIATION TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE LOVED AND
LOVED ONES OF POLICE OFFICERS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO'VE LOST
WHILE ON DUTY. IN MEMORY OF
THOSE BRAVE OFFICERS WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES IN THE COURSE
OF DUTY. I RESPECTFULLY ALSO ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
ROMBERG, YOU MAY CLOSE, YOU JUST
CAN'T SEE BECAUSE. SORRY, THE
GREAT SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD
WAS BLOCKING MY VIEW THERE.
SENATOR. SENATOR, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. TODAY MEMBERS, I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SCR 110. WHILE THE
MERITS OF THE RESOLUTION THÀNH
ARE ENOUGH TO SUPPORT ON ITS OWN
HONORING THE THOUSANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR ON OUR
BEHALF. I ALSO STAND IN MEMORY
OF SHERIFF DEPUTY DARNELL
CALHOUN, TO WHOM THIS RESOLUTION
MEMORIALIZES DARNELL, WHO WAS
SHOT AND KILLED RESPONDING TO A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENT IN
LAKELAND VILLAGE AREA OF MY
DISTRICT LAST YEAR, HIS FAMILY,
IN ADDITION TO THAT, DARNELL
WORKED AT A HIS FAMILY'S
BARBECUE, ESTABLISHMENT. THAT IS
QUITE GOOD, AND USED TO SERVE AS
FREQUENTLY AS WE WENT TO. THE
BARBECUE WAS ONLY A MILE FROM MY
HOUSE, SO WE KNEW HIM A LITTLE
BIT BEFORE HE BECAME A SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY. AND HE WAS A VERY
AFFABLE YOUNG MAN. WE USED TO
HAVE FUN, WHEN STANDING AROUND
WAITING FOR THE FOOD TO ARRIVE
HERE. AS LEGISLATORS, IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PASS LAWS TO
PROTECT NOT ONLY OUR COMMUNITY,
BUT ALSO TO GIVE OUR OFFICERS A
FIGHTING CHANCE. DARNELL WAS
EVERY BIT THE EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
GREAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IS
IN A COMMUNITY. HE WAS KNOWN FOR
TREATING EVERYONE WITH RESPECT.
HE UNDERSTOOD WHERE THEY WERE AT
IN THEIR LIFE. HE ALSO SHOWED
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION AND HE
WAS ALWAYS TRYING TO FIND A
SOLUTION TO AVOID MAKING ANY
ISSUE WORSE. I PERSONALLY WILL
BE KEEPING HIM AND ALL OFFICERS
IN MIND WHILE I SERVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, AND I ALSO KEEP IN
MIND HOW OUR DECISIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPACT NOT ONLY OUR
COMMUNITIES, BUT THE OFFICERS
THAT PROTECT THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS WHY I ASK ALL OF YOU TO
JOIN IN SUPPORTING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION IN HONORING
THE FALLEN OFFICERS OF OUR GREAT
STATE. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR ALVARADO HILL,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION TODAY
TO DESIGNATE MAY 6TH AS
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY. THIS DAY HOLDS
IMMENSE SIGNIFICANCE AS WE HONOR
THE BRAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE
THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN THE
LINE OF DUTY TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO DATE, THERE HAVE
BEEN 1756 LINE OF DUTY DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST
CENTURY. 36 LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN KILLED WHILE
PROTECTING AND SERVING
COMMUNITIES. IN MY STATE SENATE
DISTRICT FOUR, AND OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS, WE'VE LOST NEARLY
HALF A DOZEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO HAVE LAID THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE WHILE
PROTECTING AND SERVING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. TODAY, I WOULD LIKE
TO HONOR THE MEMORIES OF EL
DORADO COUNTY SHERIFF DEPUTY
BRIAN ISHMAEL, OR ISH, WHOSE END
OF WATCH WAS WEDNESDAY, OCTOBER
23RD, 19, 2019, DEATH AT GUNFIRE
WHILE ON ACTIVE DUTY. NEWMAN
POLICE CORPS CORPORAL RONIL
SINGH. END OF WATCH WAS
WEDNESDAY, DECEMBER 26TH. YES,
THE DAY AFTER CHRISTMAS OF 2018.
GUNFIRE ON ACTIVE DUTY
STANISLAUS COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY ANTONIO INOSTROZA, THE
THIRD JASON ALLEN GARDINER AND
DENNIS RANDALL WALLACE, END OF
WATCH. SATURDAY, MAY 13TH, 2017.
END OF WATCH SUNDAY, NOVEMBER
25TH, 2018 AND SUNDAY, NOVEMBER
13TH, 2016. AND ROBERT LEE
PARRIS JR. THURSDAY, APRIL 12TH,
20, 2012. THE STANISLAUS BLUE
LINES WIVES CLUB, A NONPROFIT
THAT WAS BUILT THAT WAS BUILT TO
SUPPORT OUR FALLEN OFFICERS, HAS
BEEN A BEACON OF SUPPORT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WIVES, MOTHERS AND
MEMBERS AND FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE LOVED THEM. TODAY, MANY OF
OUR FALLEN OFFICERS NAMES ARE
DISPLAYED WITH HONOR, ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAYS AND
INTERSTATES. A VERY IMPORTANT
REMINDER OF THE SACRIFICE. IN
RECOGNIZING MAY SIXTH AS
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY, WE WILL PAY
TRIBUTE TO THOSE WHO HAVE FALLEN
WHILE SERVING, AND WE EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE TO ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO CONTINUE TO HOLD
AND UPHOLD THEIR MEMORY, THEIR
HONOR AND MEMORIES. I STRONGLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR JONES,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SCR 110
CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL DAY. I CAN SHARE WITH
YOU THAT EVERY YEAR THAT THIS
CEREMONY BECOMES MORE AND MORE
PERSONAL TO ME, AS I'VE SHARED
IN THE PAST, THAT MY SON IN LAW
IS A POLICE OFFICER SERVING IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND,
RECOGNIZING THAT I DIDN'T GROW
UP WITH POLICE OFFICERS IN MY
FAMILY, BUT MY DAUGHTER DECIDED
TO MARRY ONE. AND NOW WE HAVE
ONE IN OUR FAMILY. AND EVERY DAY
I THINK OF THAT RESPONSIBILITY
THAT HE TAKES TO PROTECT HIS
COMMUNITY AND KEEP ALL OF US
SAFE. AND THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE, THAT I HAVE
PERSONALLY TO KNOW THAT I HAVE
HIS BACK IF ANYTHING HAPPENS. ON
ANY SHIFT THAT HE MAY SERVE AS
WE TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
END OF WATCH STORIES THAT WE
HEARD TODAY AND THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF EVENTS THAT ENDED THOSE
WATCHES. SOME OF THEM ARE
AMBUSH, SOME OF THEM WERE CAR
ACCIDENTS AND OTHER TYPES OF,
ACCIDENTS OR ON PURPOSE ACTS OF
THAT ENDED THOSE WATCHES. ONE OF
THE THINGS SOMETIMES THAT WE
FORGET ABOUT, THERE'S ALSO, AN
EPIDEMIC OF SUICIDE AMONG OUR
POLICE OFFICERS AND OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS. I SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF A NONPROFIT CALLED COVER NOW
THAT'S COMMITTED TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT OF OUR POLICE
OFFICERS, OUR POLICE OFFICERS
THAT ARE CATASTROPHICALLY
INJURED AND THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE LEFT BEHIND BY SUICIDE. THE
REASON THAT THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO ME IS I'VE DONE A RIDE ALONG
WITH POLICE. I'VE WITNESSED JUST
A FRACTION OF WHAT THEY HAVE TO
PUT UP WITH IN THEIR CAREER, AND
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL OF US IF
YOU'VE NOT DONE A RIDE ALONG
WITH YOUR LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT OR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT OR SOME TYPE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY THAT YOU
WOULD DO THAT, I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU WOULD DO THAT AS A PERSONAL
FAVOR TO ME, THAT YOU WOULD,
TAKE A LONG SHIFT, MAYBE A NIGHT
SHIFT, MAYBE ON A FRIDAY NIGHT
OR A SATURDAY NIGHT AND ASK FOR
A REAL RIDE ALONG, NOT A
SANITIZED PUBLIC OFFICIAL. WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP YOU SAFE. RIDE
ALONG. BUT MAYBE ONE WHERE YOU
MIGHT GET A LITTLE DIRTY OR
MIGHT BE A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE,
OR YOU MIGHT BE A LITTLE HUNGRY,
OR YOU MIGHT GO A LITTLE THIRSTY
BECAUSE THE SHIFT IS GOING ON
AND ON, AND THEY'RE RESPONDING
TO YOUR CALL AFTER CALL AFTER
CALL. AND JUST GET A SMALL TASTE
OF WHAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT GO
THROUGH IN THEIR CAREERS. I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SCR
110. SENATOR STERN, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE IN
SUPPORT. I JUST HAD THE HEAVY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MEET WITH
DEPUTY RYAN KLINKENBERG BOOMER'S
FAMILY. END OF WATCH WAS
SEPTEMBER 16TH OF LAST YEAR, AND
HE COMES FROM FOUR GENERATIONS
OF DEPUTIES IN THE L.A. COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT, DATING ALL
THE WAY BACK TO WHEN THEY DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE CARS IN THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY TO DO THAT WORK.
THAT WAS, A DIFFERENT TIME. AND
YET THROUGH THOSE GENERATIONS,
THEY ALL MADE IT THROUGH, AND
IT'S VERY HARD TO MEET WITH A
FAMILY WHO IS TRYING TO PUT THE
PUZZLE PIECES TOGETHER AND
FIGURE OUT WHY REALLY, REALLY
BAD THINGS HAPPEN TO SUCH
HONORABLE AND GOOD PEOPLE. AND I
DON'T THINK WE'RE WE'RE MEANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN, BECAUSE WE HAVE TO RAGE
AGAINST THOSE THINGS HAPPENING.
WE HAVE TO STOP THOSE THINGS
FROM HAPPENING AND NOT ACCEPT
THOSE AS JUST PART OF THE JOB,
WE OWE A DEEP DEBT TO THE
KLINKEN BOOMERS AND TO EVERYONE
ELSE WHO'S FALLEN INTO EVERYONE
ELSE WHO SERVES TODAY. AS I
THANK YOU, SENATOR UMBERG, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
VERY ELOQUENT COMMENTS,
PARAPHRASING GEORGE WASHINGTON,
WHO SAID THAT A YOUNG PERSON'S
PROPENSITY TO SERVE IS DIRECTLY
PROPORTIONAL TO HOW HIS OR HER
COMMUNITY RECOGNIZES THAT
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE. SO I'M
GRATEFUL, AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
GRATEFUL THAT CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL FOUNDATION FOR
PROVIDING THAT PLATFORM, SO THAT
EVERY YEAR I BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
46 YEARS. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SACRIFICE. SO ALL OF US CAN SEE
WHAT THAT MEANS. WE ENACT THE
LAWS HERE. AND OF COURSE, THOSE
WHO ARE BUT A STONE'S THROW AWAY
TODAY, THEY'RE CHARGED WITH
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENFORCING
THOSE LAWS. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT, AND I ARE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU HAVE THIS CEREMONY HERE
IN THE SHADOW OF THE CAPITOL. SO
WE ARE REMINDED OF THE FACES OF
THOSE WHO HAVE MADE THAT
SACRIFICE. SO WITH THAT, I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI. AYE.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE LAIRD. AYE. LEMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA. BOGUE. AYE PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ASHBY MCGUIRE. MIN. ISE
37. NO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN. SCR 124 I CELEBRAR
EL ESPIRITU LATINO. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO CELEBRATE THE SPIRIT OF
FILE ITEM 11. CELEBRATE THE
LATINO SPIRIT WITH SR 74.
MAJORITY LEADER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 74 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO CINCO DE
MAYO WEEK. MAJORITY LEADER,
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS, IT IS MY HONOR
TODAY TO RISE TO PRESENT SR
SENATE RESOLUTION 74, WHICH
MEMORIALIZES CINCO DE MAYO AS A
SIGNIFICANT DATE IN MEXICAN AND
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. ON MAY 5TH,
1862, AT THE BATALLA DE PUEBLA
IN MEXICO, A SMALL ARMY OF
INDIGENOUS MEXICANS,
OUTNUMBERED, FORMULATED A STRONG
RESISTANCE AND DEFEATED A FRENCH
COLONIAL FORCE, A FORCE THAT WAS
LARGER, BETTER TRAINED AND VERY
EQUIPPED. DESPITE A SEVERE LACK
OF RESOURCES, THE MEXICAN ARMY'S
DETERMINATION TO BE FREE FROM
COLONIZATION CARRIED THEM TO A
HISTORIC VICTORY. WE RECOGNIZE
CINCO DE MAYO BECAUSE IT SERVES
AS A SYMBOL OF OUR MEXICAN
CULTURE, RESILIENCE AND
CHARACTER. CINCO DE MAYO SERVES
TO REMIND US THAT THE FOUNDATION
OF OUR NATION AND OUR STATE IS
ITS PEOPLE, IN THEIR SPIRIT AND
COURAGE, IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY, IN THE STRENGTH OF
THEIR DRIVE TO ACHIEVE
SELF-DETERMINATION, AND IN THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO SACRIFICE EVEN
LIFE ITSELF IN THE PURSUIT OF
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY. LATINOS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE CHALLENGED THE
FRONTIERS OF SOCIAL, ECONOMIC,
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
HAVE STRENGTHENED AND UPLIFTED
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
COUNTLESS WAYS. WE ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ISSUES THAT IMPACT
OUR COMMUNITIES, LIVELIHOOD AND
WELL-BEING, ENSURING WE ARE
CIVICALLY ENGAGED AND
REPRESENTED AT ALL LEVELS LOCAL,
STATE AND NATIONAL. SO ON THIS
DAY WHEN WE RECOGNIZE THE
COURAGE, STRENGTH AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SYMBOLISM OF
THE VICTORY OF THE BATALLA DE
PUEBLA BY MEXICAN FORCES, THE
LATINO CAUCUS IS PROUD TO SHARE
WITH YOU THE COURAGE, STRENGTH
AND RESILIENCE THAT IS EMBODIED
IN THE SPIRIT OF THE LATINO
LEADERS WE'VE SELECTED TO
RECEIVE OUR 2024 LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS. THE BIOGRAPHIES OF OUR
LATINO HONOREES CAN BE FOUND ON
THE PROGRAMS WE HAVE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL SENATORS HERE.
THEY ARE AN EXCEPTIONAL GROUP OF
LEADERS WHO WE FEEL VERY PROUD
TO RECOGNIZE BECAUSE OF THEIR
DEDICATION AND PASSION TO
POSITIVELY REPRESENT OUR
COMMUNITIES, OUR LATINO CULTURE
AND HERITAGE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR RUBIO,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR 74, NOT
ONLY AS A MEMBER OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS, BUT ALSO AS A CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE, JEWISH CAUCUS
MEMBER. CINCO DE MAYO CELEBRATES
THE MEXICAN PEOPLE'S FIGHT FOR
LIBERATION AND
SELF-DETERMINATION. IT IS A
REMINDER THAT THE STRENGTH OF
ANY NATION LIES IN ITS PEOPLE
AND THEIR SPIRIT, AND THEIR
COURAGE TO PURSUE FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY. THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
WHO HAVE FACED PERSECUTION AND
STRUGGLES THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY, ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
LESSON. THE CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
THE MEXICAN COMMUNITY AND THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY RUN DEEP DURING
WORLD WAR TWO, MEXICO PROVIDED A
REFUGE FOR MANY JEWISH PEOPLE
SEEKING SAFE HAVENS FROM THE
HORRORS OF WAR AND GENOCIDE.
THAT WELCOMING OF DIVERSITY
MAKES OUR WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
AND TODAY, THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES OF CALIFORNIA STAND
TOGETHER AND CELEBRATION OF
CINCO DE MAYO. AS A PROUD
COAUTHOR AND ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS, I URGE AND I VOTE
ON SR 74. THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
I ALSO RISE ON BEHALF OF, SR 74
ON BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS.
AND JUST TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
INTERSECTIONALITY AMONGST SO
MANY OF US OF THE LGBT CAUCUS
AND OUR LATINO FAMILIES FROM
WHICH WE COME, STARTING WITH THE
FIGHT AT PUEBLO, THE RESILIENCE,
THE STRENGTH OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO PUSH OFF
OPPRESSORS THAT MAY BE STRONGER
THAN THEMSELVES. WE HAVE NEVER
MET A FENCE. WE COULDN'T GET
OVER. WE HAVE NEVER MET A BATTLE
THAT WE COULDN'T WIN. AND WE
KNOW THAT WE DO THAT. MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WHEN WE DO IT
TOGETHER ON OUR OWN FLOOR. HERE
WE HAVE LATINO LEADERS WHO ARE
ALSO IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY, THE
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO, WHO
REPRESENTS OUR WHOLE SOUTHERN
BORDER, A PROUD MEMBER OF BOTH
CAUCUSES, OUR MEMBER WHO'S
PRESIDING TODAY, ALSO A MEMBER
OF BOTH CAUCUSES, BEING THE
YOUNGEST MEMBER OF OUR SENATE
FAMILY. AND I AM ON THE OLDER
SIDE OF THE SENATE FAMILY. AND
COUNT MYSELF ALSO AMONGST THOSE
THAT FACE THIS
INTERSECTIONALITY, IN ADDITION
TO OUR, INSURANCE COMMISSIONER,
RICARDO LARA, IN ADDITION TO OUR
SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT, TONY
THURMOND, WE ARE PROUDLY
REPRESENTED AS WE FACE THE
INTERSECTIONALITY OF ALL OF OUR
LIVES AND FIGHT TOGETHER FOR THE
FREEDOM AND THE AND THE
PRIVILEGE TO LIVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SR 74.
COLLEAGUES, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A QUICK ONE MINUTE RECESS. NÓ,
JUST A QUICK BREAK. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? MR. PRO TEM, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE ALONGSIDE THE LATINO CAUCUS
TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE
CALIFORNIANS BEING HONORED TODAY
FOR THIS YEAR'S LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO OUR MAJORITY LEADER.
ALSO, VICE CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS, FOR BRINGING THIS
BEAUTIFUL CEREMONY TO THESE
CHAMBERS. YOU KNOW, THE HONOREES
WHO WERE CELEBRATING THIS
AFTERNOON HAVE GIVEN BACK TO
THIS STATE ALL WHO LOVE TO CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME AND HAVE MADE IT
STRONGER. AND IN EVERY CORNER OF
THE GOLDEN STATE, WE EXPERIENCED
PROFOUND CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THE GOLDEN STATE'S
LATINO COMMUNITY AND THE 15
MILLION LATINOS WHO CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME ARE A LIVING
TESTAMENT TO THAT. CALIFORNIA IS
THE MOST DIVERSE STATE IN
AMERICA, AND IT'S THAT DIVERSITY
THAT IS OUR SECRET TO SUCCESS AS
AN ECONOMIC POWER, AS THE MOST
WELCOMING STATE IN AMERICA TO
THOSE WHO SEEK A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES AS WELL AS THEIR
FAMILIES. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THE SENATE. MADAM PRESIDENT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SR 74. THANK YOU, MR.
PRO-TEM. MAJORITY LEADER. SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE.
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF THE 38 MEMBERS STRONG
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS, I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM BALDWIN PARK,
FROM STOCKTON, AS WELL AS OUR
PRO TEM, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS, THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 38
NOES ZERO RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MAJORITY LEADER UNDER PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR. PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU AGAIN, MADAM PRESIDENT.
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS, IT IS MY PLEASURE. NOW
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO SOME VERY
SPECIAL GUESTS JOINING US TODAY,
OUR 2024 LATINO SPIRIT AWARD
HONOREES. THE LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS WERE FOUNDED 23 YEARS AGO
BY THE LATINO CAUCUS TO
HIGHLIGHT, CONTRIBUTE MADE BY
LEADERS WITHIN OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITY. OUR HONOREES ARE
BOLD, INSPIRING, AND PASSIONATE
LEADERS THAT TRULY EMBODY OUR
LATINO SPIRIT, AND I AM PROUD TO
SHARE THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS WITH
YOU ALL TODAY. ALSO, THIS LATINO
SPIRIT AWARD HERE. WHICH EVERY
ONE OF OUR HONOREES WILL
RECEIVE, IS A BEAR MADE IN THE
SHAKIRA STYLE, WHICH WE HAVE
ESPECIALLY MADE FROM NAYARIT,
MEXICO. EVERY AWARD IS ITS OWN
UNIQUE PATTERN, SO NO TWO LATINO
SPIRIT AWARDS ARE THE SAME AND
WITH THAT, WE'LL START WITH OUR
VERY FIRST HONOREE. WE'LL START
OFF WITH VANESSA AGUILAR. SHE'S
A RISING STAR ON THE
INTERNATIONAL SOCCER STAGE WHO
RECENTLY PARTICIPATED IN FRANCE
WITH THE U-17 MEXICAN NATIONAL
TEAM. ORIGINALLY FROM SOLEDAD,
VANESSA BEGAN PLAYING SOCCER AT
THE AGE OF EIGHT AND HAS
RECENTLY PLAYED FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO GLENS AND THE BAY AREA
SURF, WHERE SHE DISTINGUISHED
HERSELF AS THE TOP SCORER FOR
THE ECNL LEAGUE. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING VANESSA AGUILAR AS
A 2020 FOR ACHIEVEMENT AND YOUTH
ATHLETICS HONOREE.
CONGRATULATIONS ÓRDENES! NEXT WE
HAVE RAFAEL AGUSTIN. HE'S A
WRITER ON THE AWARD WINNING TV
SHOW JANE THE VIRGIN AND IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLING
MEMOIR ILLEGALLY YOURS. AGUSTIN
WAS ALSO THE FOUNDING DIRECTOR
OF THE YOUTH CINEMA PROJECT, AND
IS A BOARD MEMBER OF THE CENTER
FOR INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING, THE
OLDEST NONPROFIT INVESTIGATIVE
NEWSROOM IN THE US. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN CINEMA AND
LITERATURE HONOREE, RAFAEL
AGUSTIN. WELCOME AND CONGRATS.
NEXT, WE HAVE A FRIEND TO MANY
OF US, CASTULO DE LA ROCHA. HE
IS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF ALTAMED
HEALTH SERVICES, WHICH
TRANSFORMED FROM A STOREFRONT
BARRIO CLINIC IN EAST LOS
ANGELES INTO ONE OF THE LARGEST
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS IN THE NATION. AN AVID
BELIEVER IN THE HEALING POWER OF
ART, MR. DE LA ROCHA HAS SPENT
30 YEARS ASSEMBLING THE ULTIMATE
ART COLLECTION, WHICH FEATURES
WORKS FROM EMERGING AND
ESTABLISHED ARTISTS AND LIVES ON
ROTATING DISPLAY ACROSS THE
ALTAMED NETWORK. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN HEALTH CARE
HONOREE, GUSTAVO DE LA ROCHA.
THANK YOU. CONGRATS. NEXT, WE
HAVE JOEL DEL BOSQUE IS A CIVIC
LEADER AND LIFELONG FARMER FROM
FIREBALL, CALIFORNIA, WHOSE FARM
PRODUCES ORGANIC MELONS, ORGANIC
TOMATOES, ALMONDS AND CHERRIES.
DEL BOSQUE IS A VOCAL ADVOCATE
FOR FARMERS IMPACTED BY WATER
POLICIES. IN 2010, HE WAS
APPOINTED TO SERVE ON THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION, AND
HE CURRENTLY SERVES ON THE AG
FOUNDATION BOARD AT FRESNO
STATE. HE IS ALSO ON THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF AMOR WELLNESS,
AND IS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA MELON RESEARCH BOARD.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
2020 FOR ACHIEVEMENT IN
AGRICULTURE BUSINESS HONOREE,
JOEL DEL BOSQUE. MIGHT
GOMEZ-REJON IS THE FOUNDER OF
ART BITES, WHERE SHE EXPLORES
THE NEXUS OF ART AND CULINARY
HISTORY THROUGH LECTURES,
TASTINGS AND COOKING IN MUSEUMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. MIGHT HIS
WRITINGS HAVE APPEARED IN MANY
PUBLICATIONS, AND HER CURATORIAL
WORK INCLUDES EXHIBITS OF THE
FORGOTTEN LEGACY OF MEXICAN
COLONIAL CULINARY PIONEER
JOSEFINA VELASQUEZ DE LEON. SHE
ALSO CO-HOSTS HUNGRY FOR HISTORY
WITH EVA LONGORIA ON
IHEARTRADIO'S MY CULTURA PODCAST
NETWORK. PLEASE JOIN ME IN IN
WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN CULINARY ARTS
HONOREE. MIGHT GOMEZ-REJON.
JORGE GUTIERREZ IS AN EMMY AWARD
WINNING ANIMATOR, PAINTER, VOICE
ACTOR, WRITER AND DIRECTOR. HE
DIRECTED AND CO-WROTE THE
ANIMATED FEATURE THE BOOK OF
LIFE, WHICH EARNED HIM A 2014
GOLDEN GLOBE AWARD NOMINATION.
HE ALSO CREATED THE NICKELODEON
ANIMATED SERIES EL TIGRE THE
ADVENTURES OF MANNY RIVERA AND
CREATED, WROTE, AND DIRECTED THE
EVENT SERIES MAYA AND THE THREE
FOR NETFLIX, WHICH WON FOUR
EMMYS. HE IS CURRENTLY WRITING
DIRECTING A NETFLIX ANIMATED
FEATURE NAMED CHIHUAHUA WITH
GABRIEL FLUFFY IGLESIAS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR 2024
ACHIEVEMENT IN ANIMATION AND
FILM HONOREE JORGE GUTIERREZ.
DORIS ANAHI MUNOZ IS A SINGER,
SONGWRITER AND ACTIVIST. SHE IS
THE FOUNDER OF SOLIDARITY FOR
SANCTUARY, A CONCERT SERIES THAT
ORIGINATED FROM A VERY PERSONAL
NEED TO HELP UNDOCUMENTED
PARENTS IN THEIR LEGAL PROCESS,
WHICH RAPIDLY GREW INTO
BENEFITING IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS FROM COAST TO
COAST. HER STORY CAUGHT THE EYE
OF DIRECTOR ISABEL CASTRO, WHO
CREATED THE FEATURE LENGTH
DOCUMENTARY MIJA ABOUT DORIS AND
HER FAMILY'S JOURNEY. DORIS HAS
RELEASED TWO EPS, APRENDIENDO
POR LAS MALAS AND POR LAS
BUENAS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN ARTS AND MUSIC
HONOREE DORIS ANAHI MUNOZ.
BELARMINO IS A RENOWNED REPORTER
FOR TELEMUNDO 48, IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WHO HAS WON TEN EMMY
AWARDS. NINO'S IMPACT TRANSCENDS
HER REPORTING. SHE COLLABORATES
WITH LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
ADDRESS PRESSING ISSUES
EMBODYING THE SPIRIT OF ACTIVISM
AND POSITIVE CHANGE. HER
IMPARTIAL STORYTELLING IS A
SOURCE OF INSPIRATION,
RESONATING WITH AUDIENCES AND
DRIVING MEANINGFUL, MEANINGFUL
DIALOG. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN JOURNALISM
HONOREE. BELARMINO. NANCY SUTLEY
IS DEPUTY MAYOR OF ENERGY AND
SUSTAINABILITY FOR LOS ANGELES
MAYOR KAREN BASS. SUTLEY
PREVIOUSLY LED THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNCIL ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
UNDER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA,
AND SERVED AS DEPUTY MAYOR FOR
ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENT UNDER THE
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ANTONIO
VILLARAIGOSA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN PUBLIC SERVICE
HONOREE, NANCY SUTLEY. MANA DE
SAN DIEGO IS THE LARGEST CHAPTER
OF THE NATIONAL LATINA
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS DONE
INVALUABLE WORK, UPLIFTING AND
ADVOCATING FOR LATINAS IN THE
SAN DIEGO REGION FOR 38 YEARS.
THEY HAVE BUILT A BELOVED
COMMUNITY OF SUPPORT TO EMPOWER
LATINAS THROUGH EDUCATION,
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT,
COMMUNITY SERVICE, AND ADVOCACY.
AT EVERY STAGE OF THEIR LIVES.
JOINING US FROM MANA TODAY ARE
BOARD CHAIR CLAUDIA REMPEL AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DOCTOR INEZ
GONZALEZ PEREZ. CHICA, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE 2020
FOR ACHIEVEMENT AND COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT HONOREE. MANA SAN
DIEGO. LUPITA INFANTE IS A
MEXICAN AMERICAN SINGER
SONGWRITER WHO HAS BEEN
NOMINATED FOR SEVERAL GRAMMY AND
LATIN GRAMMY AWARDS. HER NAME IS
FAMILIAR TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
MEXICANS AS SHE IS THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF PEDRO INFANTE,
THE MOST BELOVED MEXICAN SINGER
AND ACTOR OF THE 20TH CENTURY.
WITH A MULTITUDE OF AWARDS AND
RECOGNITIONS, AND BEING FEATURED
IN THE 2024 PEOPLE AND ESPANOL'S
MOST POWERFUL WOMEN OF 2024
LIST. LUPITA INFANTE IS
SOLIDIFYING HER PLACE AS ONE OF
THE MOST BELOVED MUSICA MEXICANA
ARTISTS OF THE NEW GENERATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
2024 ACHIEVEMENT IN MUSIC AND
ENTERTAINMENT HONOREE LUPITA
INFANTE. DOCTOR DIANA Â RAMOS
IS CALIFORNIA'S SECOND SURGEON
GENERAL AND THE FIRST LATINA TO
SERVE IN THAT ROLE AS
CALIFORNIA'S DOCTOR, SHE IS THE
LEADING SPOKESPERSON ON THE MOST
PRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE PAST THREE DECADES,
DOCTOR RAMOS HAS PROVIDED
REPRODUCTIVE CARE TO THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS. AS AN
OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGIST.
DOCTOR RAMOS ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF CHRONIC DISEASE
PREVENTION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
PLEASE JOIN ME. JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN PUBLIC SERVICE
AND HEALTH. CALIFORNIA'S SURGEON
GENERAL, DOCTOR DIANA Â RAMOS.
IGNACIO GOMEZ IS A WORLD
RENOWNED PAINTER AND SCULPTOR
WHOSE PAINTING OF EDWARD JAMES
OLMOS AS EL PACHUCO FOR THE
BROADWAY PLAY ZOOT SUIT, IS NOW
IN THE COLLECTION OF THE
SMITHSONIAN AMERICAN ART MUSEUM.
GOMEZ ALSO DESIGNED, SCULPTED
AND PAINTED CESAR CHAVEZ
MEMORIAL FOR THE CITY OF SAN
FERNANDO, THE CHAVEZ HEADSTONE
IN LA PAZ, KEEN, AND THE CHAVEZ
MEMORIAL IN THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN ART AND CIVIL
RIGHTS HONOREE IGNACIO GOMEZ, AN
AN ARMY VETERAN. DOCTOR JOSE
HERNANDEZ IS A FORMER MIGRANT
WORKER WHO BECAME AN ASTRONAUT
FOR NASA AND SERVED AS FLIGHT
ENGINEER FOR THE 2009 STS 128
MISSION ABOARD THE SPACE SHUTTLE
DISCOVERY. DOCTOR HERNANDEZ
SPENT MORE THAN 15 YEARS AT THE
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE NATIONAL
LABORATORY, WHERE HE
CO-DEVELOPED THE FIRST FULL
FIELD DIGITAL MAMMOGRAPHY SYSTEM
FOR THE EARLY DETECTION OF
BREAST CANCER. DOCTOR HERNANDEZ
CURRENTLY WORKS AS A CONSULTANT
FOR THE COMPANY HE FOUNDED IN
2012, TIERRA LUNA ENGINEERING,
AND SERVES ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS. HIS
LIFE STORY WAS ALSO THE SUBJECT
OF THE AMAZON PRIME BIOPIC A
MILLION MILES AWAY. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN SCIENCE AND
PHILANTHROPY. DOCTOR JOSE M
HERNANDEZ. I WILL ASK THAT ALL
THE HONOREES COME TO THE FRONT
OF THE. WE HAVE OH, WE HAVE TWO
I, I APOLOGIZE, THAT'S OKAY.
THAT IS OKAY. ALL GOOD. YES. AND
I SAVED THE BEST FOR LAST. AND
OUR LAST TWO HONOREES ARE
CO-FOUNDERS OF LATINAS ACTING
UP. AN ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS
UNDERPAID AND EXPLOITED LATINAS
ACROSS THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. LISA VIDAL IS A
VETERAN TELEVISION AND FILM
ACTRESS WHOSE CREDITS INCLUDE
THE BAKER AND THE BEAUTY, BOSTON
LEGAL, CSI MIAMI, ER AND THE
2009 FILM STAR TREK. DIANA MARIA
RIVA IS AN ACTRESS AND ADVOCATE
WHO STARRED IN MCFARLAND, USA,
LOVE AND MERCY, AND HAS APPEARED
IN MANY PROMINENT SERIES
INCLUDING NYPD BLUE, THE WEST
WING, AND THE GORDITA
CHRONICLES. PLEASE JOIN ME! JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING OUR 2020 FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN ADVOCACY AND
ENTERTAINMENT HONOREES.
CO-FOUNDERS OF LATINAS ACTING UP
, LISA VIDAL AND DIANA MARIA
RIVA. MEMBERS AND GUESTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEARING WITH US
AND WE ARE SO HONORED AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE 30 MEMBERS OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OF THESE INCREDIBLE HONOREES ARE
UPLIFTED AND THAT WE GIVE THEM
OUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I'M
GOING TO HAVE ALL THE HONOREES
COME NOW TO THE FRONT. THE FIRST
PHOTO IS GOING TO BE WITH THE
LATINO, LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
AFTER THAT PHOTO, THE REST OF
THE REST OF THE MEMBERS COULD
JOIN THE GROUP PHOTO IF THEY
WISH
.
IF ANY OTHER MEMBER WOULD WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
GROUP PHOTO. NOW IS THE TIME
.
NOW IS THE TIME TO JOIN THE
GROUP PHOTO. FOR ANY OTHER
MEMBER WHO WISHES TO PARTICIPATE
.
THAT WAS REALLY
WE'LL COME BACK IN. 60S.
I THINK, LIKE, ALMOST TWO.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, IF WE CAN
GET BACK TO OUR DESK, WE ARE
RESUMING WITH OUR AGENDA. HERE
WE GO. IF WE STILL NEED TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION, IF WE CAN PLEASE
TAKE IT OFF THE FLOOR. MOVING ON
TO ANNOUNCE, SENATOR GLAZER, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. GLASER. GLASER OKAY,
MEMBERS. LAST YEAR, I AUTHORED
AND YOU PASSED A RESOLUTION THAT
NAMED THE PLAZA OF THE STATE
CAPITOL. WORLD PEACE ROSE
GARDEN, IN HONOR OF CHIEF
JUSTICE ROSE ELIZABETH BIRD AS
YOU KNOW, THE FIRST WOMAN TO SIT
ON THE SUPREME COURT. TOMORROW
MORNING, THERE IS A CEREMONY TO
UNVEIL THE. THAT RECOGNITION AND
THAT HONOR AT 10 A.M. IN THE
ROSE GARDEN IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. I WANT TO INVITE
ANY MEMBERS WHO'S HERE IN THE
MORNING TO COME JOIN THAT
IMPORTANT CEREMONY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, WE'RE NOW
ENTERING OUR RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
ENTERING THE TIME FOR ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES. WE HAVE TWO TODAY
SENATORS, LET'S GIVE OUR
ATTENTION TO FIRST SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON, COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF THE GREAT
REVEREND DOCTOR CECIL CHIPMAN
GRAY, A FIERCE CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADER WHO FOR DECADES WAS AN
INFLUENTIAL VOICE FOR SOUTH LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT. REVEREND MURRAY WAS
THE LEGENDARY PROPHETIC PASTOR
OF FIRST AME METHODIST EPISCOPAL
CHURCH OF LOS ANGELES, BETTER
KNOWN AS FAME CHURCH. THE CITY'S
OLDEST BLACK CONGREGATION AND A
LEADING CENTER FOR RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE MOVEMENTS. IT
WAS A PLACE WHERE MANY WOULD
GATHER TO SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER IN
THE TIMES OF CHALLENGE, AND ALSO
TO CELEBRATE OUR COMMUNITY IN
TIMES OF VICTORY. AND WHILE MANY
WILL RECALL FAME FOR THE HIGH
PROFILE GUESTS SUCH AS US
PRESIDENTS AND GOVERNORS COMING
TO VISIT CELEBRITIES AND
ATHLETES, FOR THOSE OF US WHO
LIVED IN SOUTH LA, IT WAS JUST
KNOWN AS THE PLACE WHERE
REVEREND MURRAY PASTORED AND
WHERE A REAL IMPACT WAS MADE ON
THE LIVES OF THE CONGREGANTS AND
ON THE LIFE OF THE COMMUNITY,
PARTICULARLY THE WEST ADAMS
NEIGHBORHOOD. FAME CHURCH WAS
FOUNDED IN 1872 BY BIDDY MASON
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
PASTOR MURRAY BY UNDERSTANDING
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS CHURCH.
BIDDY MASON WAS A FORMER SLAVE
WHO WALKED BY FOOT TO TRAVEL
BEHIND HER SLAVE MASTER AND HIS
CARAVAN FROM MISSISSIPPI TO THE
WEST IN 1848, AND AFTER LEARNING
THAT CALIFORNIA WAS FREE, BIDDY
MASON PETITIONED FOR HER FREEDOM
, AND SHE SETTLED IN LOS
ANGELES, WHERE SHE BECAME A
PROMINENT LANDOWNER. SHE
PROVIDED CARE SERVICES IN HER
COMMUNITY AND ULTIMATELY A
PHILANTHROPIST AND FOUNDER OF
THE GREAT FAME CHURCH. IT'S NOT
A COINCIDENCE THAT THIS CHURCH
AND ITS RICH HISTORY WOULD BE
CONNECTED WITH SUCH A GREAT AND
PHENOMENAL, LOVING LEADER AS
PASTOR MURRAY. IN 1977, REVEREND
MURRAY BEGAN HIS 27 YEAR
PASTORSHIP OF FAME. HE TOOK THE
CHURCH OF A FEW HUNDRED MEMBERS
AND GREW IT TO A CONGREGATION OF
NEARLY 20,000 DURING HIS TENURE,
BECOMING THE LARGEST BLACK
CHURCH, ONE OF THE LARGEST BLACK
CHURCHES IN THE COUNTRY, AND
PASTOR MURRAY DID THIS WITH SUCH
A GENTLE SPIRIT. HE WAS SUCH A
KIND MAN WHO EAGERLY WELCOMED
ALL INTO HIS SANCTUARY. HE OFTEN
CALLED THEM SON AND DAUGHTER,
AND I'M SO HONORED TO HAVE BEEN
ONE OF THE ONES THAT HE CALLED
DAUGHTER AS A YOUNG ORGANIZER,
WHERE HE WELCOMED ME INTO THE
CONGREGATION AND TALKED ABOUT
THE LINKS BETWEEN TÍNH,
CHRISTIANITY AND JUSTICE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. HE WOULD ENVELOP
YOU IN THAT WARMTH REGARDLESS OF
YOUR AGE, YOUR ETHNICITY, YOUR
RACE AND RELIGION. AND HE WOULD
BRING THAT BEAMING SMILE AND
CHARISMATIC PRESENCE AS THE REAL
QUALITIES OF A TRUSTED LEADER, A
LEADER WHO WAS TRUSTED, TRUSTED
WITH, WITH, WITH OUR COMMUNITY
IN THE MOST DIFFICULT OF TIMES
IN TIMES OF UNREST. HE WAS A GO
TO FOR SO MANY OF US. AND AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE RACIAL TENSION IN
LOS ANGELES AFTER THE BRUTAL
BEATING OF RODNEY KING, IT WAS
REVEREND MURRAY WHO REALLY ROSE
TO NATIONAL PROMINENCE AS THE
UNIFIER. HE BECAME A VOICE OF
PEACE AND OF ACTIVISM, AND
ENSURED THAT LOS ANGELES WOULD
OVERCOME AND BE MORE UNITED IN
THE MIDST OF THE CITY'S WORST
VIOLENCE AND UPRISING SINCE THE
1990 TWO WATTS REBELLION IN 19
I'M SORRY, 1960 FIVE WATTS
REBELLION. BEFORE THE RELEASE OF
THE VERDICTS OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE POLICE OFFICERS TRIAL FOR
THE BEATING, REVEREND MURRAY
BROUGHT EVERYONE INTO THE
CHURCH. HE OPENED THE DOORS OF
THE CHURCH FOR THAT WHOLE DAY
AND EVENING, AND HE WARNED FROM
THE PULPIT THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO BURN SOMETHING DOWN, DON'T
BURN DOWN THE HOUSES OF THE
VICTIMS. DON'T BURN DOWN THE
HOUSES OF YOUR COMMUNITY. BURN
DOWN THE LEGISLATURE, BURNED
DOWN THE BALLOT BOX, BURNED DOWN
THE COURTROOM, BURN IT ALL DOWN
BY VOTING AND GETTING INVOLVED,
BROTHER. AND HE CALLED ON
MEMBERS OF THE CONGREGATION,
PARTICULARLY THE MEN IN THE
CONGREGATION, TO STAND UP AND TO
GO OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY. THAT
EVENING TO MENTOR OTHERS AND TO
CREATE PEACE ON THE STREETS, TO
HELP RESIDENTS HEAL FROM THE
CIVIL UNREST. WHEN THE
REBUILDING EFFORTS BEGAN,
REVEREND MURRAY REACHED OUT TO
CORPORATE DONORS AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND RAISED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO LAUNCH FAME RENAISSANCE,
WHICH BECAME AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENGINE FOR SOUTH LOS
ANGELES ALONG THE WEST ADAMS
CORRIDOR, AN AREA THAT HAD BEEN
LARGELY IGNORED. THIS CHURCH
INVESTED MILLIONS TO REBUILD OLD
AND FAME BY ITSELF, CREATED OVER
4000 JOBS, CREATED 300 NEW
HOMEOWNERS, AND HELPED TO SEED
500 NEW BUSINESSES. IN THE WAKE
OF THE UNREST. THE EFFECTS ARE
STILL STANDING TODAY AND IS A
SYMBOL OF THE RESURGENCE OF THIS
CORRIDOR, PASTOR MURRAY SAID.
THE ROLE OF THE CHURCH WAS TO BE
A FUELING STATION FOR SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES THAT COULD
REALLY HELP AND HEAL THE CITY
LONG TERM. COMMITTED TO BUILDING
A VIBRANT BLACK COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES, REVEREND
MURRAY ALSO EMPHASIZED THE NEED
TO CREATE FUTURE LEADERS AND
ONCE RETIRED AS PASTOR, HE WENT
ON TO SERVE AS TANSEY PROFESSOR
OF CHRISTIAN ETHICS AND THE
CHAIR OF THE CECIL MURRAY CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AT USC.
THERE HE TRAINED NEARLY 1000
FAITH LEADERS IN WHAT WE CALLED,
AND HE COINED THE MURRAY METHOD.
AND THE MURRAY METHOD WAS SIMPLY
ABOUT BEING ON THE GROUND AND
INVOLVED IN YOUR COMMUNITY. WHAT
HE TALKED ABOUT WERE THE FIVE
M'S, THE MISSION OF THE CHURCH
BEING FELT IN THE COMMUNITY, THE
FOCUS ON THE MEMBERSHIP AND
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THOSE IN THE CONGREGATION AND
BUILDING MEMBERSHIP IN THE
COMMUNITY. MURRAY TÊ MEANING
THAT WE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND MAINTENANCE,
MEANING WE NEEDED TO CARE, BUT
MOST OF ALL MORALE, MEANING THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE VOICE OF
JUSTICE INSIDE OF OUR
CONGREGATIONS, BUILDING THE
MORALE OF OUR CHURCH AND OUR
COMMUNITY. THESE WERE ALL KEY
ATTRIBUTES THAT PASTOR MURRAY
TAUGHT SO MANY OTHER LEADERS
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY, NOT JUST
TO BUILD CHURCHES, BUT TO
TRANSFORM COMMUNITIES. REVEREND
MURRAY FOREVER TOUCHED THE LIVES
OF THOSE WHO HAD THE HONOR TO
WORK AND WORSHIP ALONGSIDE OF
HIM, AND I AM BLESSED AGAIN TO
SAY THAT I WAS A GROUP OF A
CADRE OF ORGANIZERS, YOUNG BLACK
ORGANIZERS, THAT HE WOULD
WELCOME INTO THE CHURCH OVER A
MEAL TO HAVE A CONVERSATION, AND
TO FIGURE OUT WAYS THAT THE
CHURCH COULD SUPPORT EFFORTS
LIKE OUR JUSTICE FOR JANITORS
MOVEMENT IN LOS ANGELES. HE WAS
ONE OF THE FEW PASTORS WHO STOOD
WITH A LARGELY IMMIGRANT WORKING
FORCE, UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS, TO
SAY THAT THEY ARE PART OF LOS
ANGELES AND DESERVE JUSTICE AND
AFTER THOSE WORKERS WERE
ORGANIZED, HE STOOD WITH THE
PRIVATE SECURITY OFFICERS. THESE
WERE LARGELY BLACK MEN AND WOMEN
IN THOSE SAME BUILDINGS. TO SAY
THAT THEY TOO DESERVED JUSTICE.
AND WE HOSTED A NUMBER OF
TEACHINGS IN THE CHURCH,
BRINGING HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND WORKERS TO CREATE
THE LINK BETWEEN WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE GODLIKE IN THE CHURCH, BUT
ALSO WHAT IT MEANS TO BE GODLIKE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND IN OUR
WORK SITES. I SAW HOW PASTOR
MURRAY WAS A TRUE MORAL
AUTHORITY THAT HELPED TO LEAD
AND GUIDE THIS GREAT COMMUNITY
OF SOUTH L.A. FROM THE PULPITS
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
REVEREND MURRAY WAS LAID TO REST
THIS WEEKEND. AND THE CHURCH WAS
OVERFLOWING WITH GUESTS WHO CAME
OVER HIS PASSING, WHICH WAS
EARLIER IN THE MONTH, TO PAY
THEIR RESPECTS AND GIVE THEIR
LOVE TO THIS AMAZING LEADER WHO
LED AN EXTRAORDINARY LIFE AND
ALSO MADE OUR LIVES TOUCHED BY
HIS MERE PRESENCE. HE IS A,
SURVIVED BY HIS SON, DREW
MURRAY, AND ALSO BY HIS TAMMY,
HIS NIECE, TAMMY MURRAY, AND HIS
GRAND NIECE, APRIL KHÎI AND
REVEREND MATHIS MURRAY, WHO ARE
IN THE GALLERY WITH US TODAY.
AND I THINK THEY ARE. THERE THEY
ARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US. AND WITH THAT, I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO, JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY ADD MY VOICE TO THE
GERMAN OF AN AMAZING RELIGIOUS
LEADER, CIVIC LEADER, A
VISIONARY, A HUSBAND, A FATHER,
A FRIEND AND A MENTOR TO MANY.
NONE OTHER THAN THE ONE AND ONLY
REVEREND CECIL CHIP MURRAY. AND
I'M HONORED TO CALL HIM MY
PASTOR. ALMOST 40 YEARS AGO, I
WAS ENCOURAGED TO GO TO THIS
CHURCH AND VISIT BY ONE OF MY
COWORKERS. WHEN I WORKED AT IBM,
AND HE WAS THE CHOIR DIRECTOR,
AND HE SAID, STEVE, YOU NEED TO
COME TO CHURCH ON SUNDAY AND
JUST EXPERIENCE THE CHOIR. AND
I'LL NEVER FORGET THAT FIRST DAY
I WALKED INTO THE CHURCH AND IT
WAS LIKE NOTHING I HAD EVER
HEARD OR SEEN BEFORE, BECAUSE IT
WAS THE FIRST TIME I HAD SEEN A
CHOIR WITH ELECTRIC GUITAR AND
BASS, A SAXOPHONE AND DRUMS
USING MOST CHURCHES JUST HAVE A
PIANO AND POSSIBLY AN ORGANIST,
AND HE HAD A FULL BAND. AND THIS
IS ONE OF THE LIVELIEST CHOIRS I
HAD EVER SEEN. BUT WHAT PUT THAT
TO, YOU KNOW, ON THE SIDE WAS
WHEN THIS DYNAMIC, CHARISMATIC,
BOOMING PASTOR WITH THIS
BARITONE VOICE OF CONFIDENCE, OF
, OF POWER, OF ELOQUENCE STARTED
PREACHING. AND I SAY, REVEREND
MURRAY WAS NOT A PREACHER. HE
WAS A TEACHER. HE WAS A TEACHER
OF THE WORD. AND HE MADE IT
PLAIN LIKE I HAD NEVER HEARD IT
BEFORE. AS A YOUNG PERSON. AND
AFTER VISITING ABOUT THREE
SUNDAYS IN A ROW, I MADE THE
DECISION THAT THIS IS WHERE I
WAS GOING TO CALL HOME. AND IT
WAS THE FIRST CHURCH I EVER
JOINED OUTSIDE OF MY FAMILY. AS
AN ADULT. DOH'T AT FIRST, AND ME
AND CECIL MURRAY COINED THE
PHRASE FIRST TO SERVE BECAUSE HE
BELIEVED THAT THE CHURCH SHOULD
NOT ONLY BE IN THE COMMUNITY,
BUT OF THE COMMUNITY, AND THE
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE OF THE
CHURCH. THAT'S WHY IT WAS SO
MANY ATHLETES, ENTERTAINERS,
BUSINESS PEOPLE, EDUCATOR
LEADERS, AND YES, ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
THAT CHURCH BECAUSE HE BELIEVED
IN BRINGING US ALL TOGETHER AND
JUST BEING MORE THAN JUST A
SPIRITUAL LEADER. AND I WILL
QUICKLY REMEMBER, ON THE DAY OF
THE VERDICT, HE QUICKLY
ASSEMBLED ELECTED OFFICIALS,
BUSINESS PEOPLE, YOU NAME IT,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZERS AT THE
CHURCH THAT EVENING THAT
TUESDAY, I WAS THERE AND HE
EXUDED CALM IN THE MOMENT OF
CHAOS AND CONFUSION AND FEAR.
AND HE CALMED US ALL. AND I'LL
NEVER FORGET WALKING OUT THAT
CHURCH, THAT EVENING AND THE
GLOW THAT I SAW AROUND THE CITY,
BECAUSE IT WAS FIRES ALL AROUND
AND THAT NEXT DAY, HE QUICKLY
ORGANIZED MEN OF FAME BECAUSE
MANY OF THE FIREFIGHTERS WOULD
NOT RESPOND. AND HE ASSEMBLED
MEN TO SAFEGUARD THE
FIREFIGHTERS AS IF THEY WHEN
THEY PUT OUT THE FIRES. BUT I'LL
NEVER FORGET HIS SERMON THAT
FIRST SUNDAY AFTER, THE CIVIL
UNREST HAD UNBROKE, AND HE WAS
QUICK TO ADMONISH ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD WENT OUT
INTO COMMUNITY AND SET FIRES.
AND HE QUICKLY SAID, YOU'RE
BURNING DOWN YOUR OWN COMMUNITY.
BUT HE WAS QUICK TO ALSO LET
THEM KNOW HE DID NOT BLAME THOSE
FOLKS. HE SAYS, YOU MIGHT HAVE
SET THOSE FIRES, BUT YOU DIDN'T
START THOSE FIRES. HE SAYS.
SLAVERY IN THIS COUNTRY STARTED
THIS FIRE. OUR CONSTITUTION HAD
IDENTIFIED AFRICAN AMERICANS AS
ONLY 3/5 OF A HUMAN BEING
STARTED THIS FIRE. THE ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE THAT EXISTED IN
MINORITY COMMUNITIES START
STARTED THESE FIRES AND HE WAS
VERY DELIBERATE ABOUT MAKING
THAT MESSAGE SO PLAIN AND SO
CLEAN, CLEAR. AND ALSO, SHORTLY
AFTER MAGIC JOHNSON RETIRED FROM
THE NBA BECAUSE HE ACQUIRED HIV
AGAIN, HE ASSEMBLED ATHLETES AND
ENTERTAINERS TO CREATE A MESSAGE
OF AWARENESS ABOUT AIDS. AND HE
WAS PROBABLY ONE OF THE FIRST
PASTORS TO DISTRIBUTE CONDOMS TO
THE COMMUNITY, MAKING SURE THAT
THEY WERE SAFE. AND THAT'S
UNHEARD OF IN MOST RELIGIOUS
ENVIRONMENTS. AND BUT THAT'S WHO
CECIL MURRAY WAS. I'M HONORED TO
CALL HIM MY PASTOR. WE COULD BE
HERE ALL DAY TALKING ABOUT ALL
THAT HE'S DONE AND ALL THAT HE
MEANT TO THIS COMMUNITY. AND I'M
JUST SAYING I'M HONORED TO CALL
HIM A FRIEND. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, I'M HONORED TO CALL
HIM A PASTOR. AND HE WILL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN. HE HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON FIRST
A.M.E, BUT NOT JUST FIRST A.M.E.
THE NATION. AND AGAIN, HE
PERFORMED THE FUNERAL FOR TOM
BRADLEY FOR RAY CHARLES AND
EAZY-E, BECAUSE THAT'S WHO HE
WAS. THEY ALL KNEW HIM. THEY ALL
LOVED HIM, AND THEY ALL RESPECT
HIM. SO GOD REST CECIL MURRAY
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY. WE EXTEND OUR
CONDOLENCES TO YOU AND TO THE
GOOD REVEREND'S FAMILY. SENATOR,
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
THAT WE MAY PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
HIM IN THE JOURNAL. SENATOR
NEIL, YOUR YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS A LIFE WELL LIVED IS NOT
A FUNCTION OF HOW LONG THAT LIFE
IS. A LIFE WELL LIVED IS ONE OF
PURPOSE, OF DEDICATION AND
FILLED WITH SELFLESS HELP OF
OTHERS, ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE
OF GREAT CHALLENGES. I RISE TO
HONOR AND ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF DANIEL MANDELA'S LIFE. DANIEL
PASSED AWAY NOVEMBER 29TH OF
JUST LAST YEAR. SHE WAS 37 YEARS
OLD, 37. SHE LEAVES TO MOURN IN
HER PASSING AND CELEBRATE HER
LEGACY. A WIDE CIRCLE OF FAMILY
AND FRIENDS, SOME OF WHOM WERE
INTRODUCED EARLIER WHEN SENATOR
LAIRD PRESENTED HIS RESOLUTION
ON. DANIEL WAS A BELOVED STAFF
MEMBER OF THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS
RESEARCH INSTITUTE AND MEMBER OF
THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS COMMUNITY.
SHE WILL BE LONG REMEMBERED FOR
HER UNCONDITIONAL GIVING OF
HERSELF, HER VISION AND CAPACITY
TO EXCEL, AND HER COMMITMENT TO
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS. SHE WAS
BORN ON OCTOBER 9TH, 1986, IN
SACRAMENTO, WHERE MOST OF HER
LARGE FAMILY RESIDES, AND SHE
GRADUATED FROM ROCKLAND HIGH
SCHOOL. DANIELLE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH CYSTIC FIBROSIS AT THREE
MONTHS OLD. SHE LIVED HER ENTIRE
LIFE WITH IT. AS A TEENAGER, HER
HEALTH DECLINED RAPIDLY, AND IN
2003 SHE BECAME ONE OF ONLY A
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE IN THE NATION
TO BECOME A LIVING DONOR, LUNG
TRANSPLANT RECIPIENT. EACH OF
HER PARENTS, TERRY AND DANIEL,
WHO ARE HERE WITH US TODAY,
DONATE A LOBE OF THEIR LUNGS FOR
THEIR DAUGHTER. THOSE LUNGS
SUSTAIN DANIELLE FOR OVER 20
YEARS, BUT CHRONIC REJECTION AND
OTHER TRANSPLANT RELATED
COMPLICATIONS ULTIMATELY CLAIMED
HER LIFE. DANIELLE VOLUNTEERED
WITH CYSTIC FIBROSIS RESEARCH
INSTITUTE FOR MANY YEARS PRIOR
TO JOINING THE STAFF AS A SOCIAL
MEDIA ASSOCIATE. IN THAT ROLE,
SHE EXPANDED THE INSTITUTE'S
REACH AROUND THE GLOBE AND
CREATED CONNECTIONS WITHIN THE
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
CYSTIC FIBROSIS COMMUNITY. SHE
ALSO SERVED ON THE RETREAT
COMMITTEE AND THE CYSTIC
FIBROSIS ADULT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE, AND LAUNCHED THEIR
NOW ANNUAL DANCE LIKE A FOOL
EVENT THAT RAISED RAISES FUNDS
FOR WELLNESS CLASSES FOR THE
NATIONAL CYSTIC FIBROSIS
COMMUNITY. DANIELLE WAS A
COMMITTED AND PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE WITH CYSTIC
FIBROSIS AND OTHER DISABILITIES.
SHE PARTICIPATED IN ADVOCACY
EVENTS HERE AT THE CAPITOL, AND
USED SOCIAL MEDIA TO INFORM THE
COMMUNITY OF ISSUES IMPACTING
ACCESS TO THERAPIES AND CARE.
NOW, TO END ON A MORE UPBEAT
NOTE, SHE WAS ALSO A TALENTED
IMPROV ARTIST. DANIELLE WAS A
PRODUCTION MANAGER AT STAB COM,
A COMEDY THEATER IN SACRAMENTO.
SHE POSSESSED A SHARP WIT AND A
DRY SENSE OF HUMOR AND THAT
MEMBERS IS A LIFE TRULY WELL
LIVED. SHE LIVED WITH GRACE,
INTENT AND FOCUS UNTIL HER LAST
BREATH. HER PROFOUND IMPACT ON
THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS COMMUNITY
AND ALL WHO KNEW HER WILL ENDURE
. THANK YOU FOR SHARING HER
STORY WITH US, SENATOR. PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO THAT
WE MAY MEMORIALIZE HER IN THE
JOURNAL IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR GROVE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU, MR.
MADAM PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, IT
IS NOW 330. AN ADJOURNMENT
MOTION IS MADE AND WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9 A.M.
PLEASE BE PROMPT. IT WILL BE AN
EXCITING DAY. THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY, MAY 9TH AT 9 A.M.